[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROMAN NURIK: Hello there.
And welcome once again to
"Android Design in Action."
I'm Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Hey, guys.
My name is Adam Koch.
NICK BUTCHER: And hi.
I'm Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: And today's episode
is all about common UX
issues, or anti patterns,
as we'll call them.
So let's just jump into the
slides here, since we have a
lot to cover.
Just a bit of background.
Our team, the developer
relations team for Android, we
do lots and lots of different
reviews for apps.
We will look at apps in both a
formal and informal setting.
Formally, internally we have
a review process that we
look at apps for.
This is completely separate from
editorial featuring, or
anything like that.
We just look at apps and we
provide feedback to some of
our app developers that
we work with.
And then in an informal setting,
obviously, we're
always looking at apps, getting
APK links sent over to
us in Google+.
And we're looking at them and
providing our feedback.
And so over the past few years
of doing this I guess, we're
noticed a couple of trends.
A couple of recurring
issues that seem to
affect a lot of apps.
Not every app, for certain,
but lots of apps.
And so we wanted to put
together an episode of
"Android Design in Action" where
we highlight the top 10
items that we keep seeing
over and over again.
So before we jump in, anything
else you guys want to say
about our review?
NICK BUTCHER: So that's what
you meant by formal or
informal setting.
I thought you mean
sometimes review
apps in the bar, sometimes.
ADAM KOCH: We: should review
apps in the bar, actually.
Good idea.
ROMAN NURIK: At a gala, maybe.
OK, so let's jump in.
So these are our top 10 Android
UX anti-patterns.
Before we jump in, a lot
of this stuff is
not necessarily negative.
It's really constructive
criticism via the ideas that
you guys take some of this
feedback and see how you can
improve your apps.
And so with much love, these are
our top 10 anti-patterns
that we've noticed.
So let's jump in.
The first is--
and we have funny little titles
at the top, so enjoy.
The first is, thou must
load this, or else.
Basically modal loading
dialogues.
And these are basically-- and
it's pretty obvious, right?
It's dialogues that appear that
say loading, or saving,
or sending, or whatever.
And sometimes you can't even
press Back to cancel.
If you have poor network
connectivity, there's just no
way out, except for
pressing Hoe.
And it's one of the easiest ways
to tick off your users.
Especially those that, like
I said, aren't in a good
connectivity setting.
Or those that simply
are very quickly.
They're trying to do a bunch
of things at once.
The other thing I'll quickly
point out is, one of my pet
peeves is when you throw up
a loading dialogue when
switching tabs.
Because basically, you
switch to tab.
Maybe you accidentally
chose that tab.
And now you have to wait for
that tab to load to switch to
something else.
So the solution to this is
really to try to use inline
loading spinners instead, like
in this little graphic here.
Or better yet, just try to load
data in the background
where possible, so that you
can generally just avoid
[? showing ?] loading
spinners.
So that's my, I guess, the
number 10 in the list.
Anything else before
we move on, guys?
ADAM KOCH: One thing that just
really annoys me, though, is
when I touch on a
list of items.
And I go to the details,
and then it throws up
that loading spinner.
And then I hit Back, and I can't
go back to the list of
items again.
It's just so frustrating.
NICK BUTCHER: I think generally,
dialogues are
fairly poor [INAUDIBLE].
Generally anything that's
blocking, anything that says
you have to deal with
this first.
Unless it's completely
unavoidable, then try and
avoid dialogues.
But especially learning
dialogues.
ROMAN NURIK: Absolutely.
OK, moving on?
ADAM KOCH: Let's go
to number nine.
In the wise words of MC Hammer,
can't touch this.
So we've brought this up
many times in ADIA.
And this is definitely a
recurring theme we see when
we're looking at apps.
So the first one is small
touch targets.
So really, all touch targets
should be 48dp.
We did write here that it could
go down to 38dp if you
absolutely need to.
But really, 48dp is what you
should be aiming for.
Why?
Because that's sort of maps to
roughly nine millimeters, or I
think somewhere between seven
and nine with a little bit of
variability.
Which really ends up being the
perfect touch size for the
average person's fingers.
So unless, I guess, you're
targeting a particular user
group with extremely small
hands, many babies, you should
really be shooting
for 48dp here.
And then the second one-- and
this is something we see
frequently, all the time--
is no touch feedback.
And if you put an app in front
of any of us, you'll probably
see one of the first things
we do is we actually
go and touch something.
And then we slide our finger off
a little bit, just to see
if there's any touch
feedback there.
So it's a pretty common mistake
to make, especially
when you're not using the
standard button components.
Because you may have to do a
little bit of extra work to
add that touch feedback.
But it really means that your
app feels much more
responsive.
ROMAN NURIK: And I think it's
also-- the no touch feedback,
as well as the previous
anti-pattern--
it really changes your app's
feeling of perceived latency.
When things don't respond, or
you can't do certain things,
there's an increased sense
of perceived latency.
Or users perceive that
your app is slower
than it actually is.
So it's one of the fastest--
people talk about speed
all the time.
Let's make our app faster,
faster, faster.
It's not just about raw speed.
It's really about
perceived speed.
ADAM KOCH: And the
funny thing is--
go ahead, Nick.
NICK BUTCHER: Sorry, I was going
to say, I think it's
really important when
[INAUDIBLE]
tools like digital interfaces.
Where the hottest style is all
about white space, and
[INAUDIBLE], and so on.
And it's really important to
communicate what is tappable.
What you can interact with.
And I think touch feedback is
something that instantly
reacts to you and lights up the
entire area which you can
interact with.
Will communicate back to you.
And so you'll know next time,
all right, this is the area I
have to play with.
It's really important.
ADAM KOCH: Cool, all right.
Should we move on?
ROMAN NURIK: Yep.
So number eight,
visual design.
I think this was the one
I'll talk about.
So in general, design does not
mean playing with Photoshop
until you use all
of the effects.
Until you use all of the layer
effects, like here on the
left, with the drop shadows
and all of that.
There are a couple of concepts
here going on.
Basically, when you think about
visual design for your
app, focus really on content,
rather than Chrome.
Users really aren't installing
your app just to see the
pretty buttons, and the
pretty top bars, and
all these fancy things.
They're really installing your
app, probably because they
care about the content or the
functionality that you offer.
So really make that shine.
If you're going to dedicate any
sort of visual attention
or visual resources to anything,
it should really be
the content.
Additionally, a couple of other
things in the realm of
visual styling for your app.
Try to be consistent.
All too often, we see apps
that have three or four
different button styles,
or check
box styles, or something.
And they're kind of mixing
and matching.
And generally, that can be the
result of too many people, too
many cooks in the kitchen.
Too many people working
on the same app.
So where possible, try to
introduce consistency, using
things like Android's styles
and themes, framework, to
basically make it
really simple.
To have consistent style
across your app.
And the last thing in the realm
of visual design is poor
attention to detail.
So it's not only about getting
the high level things right.
Like getting the right color
and getting the right basic
theme down.
It's really about attention to
details, with respect to
typography.
Making sure you're using the
right typographic palette.
Also, with respect to metrics.
That's one of the biggest things
that people do wrong
that we see.
Is developers don't use
the right spacing.
So there's two little space.
Or there's too much space
around an element.
Or too small margins
around the sides.
And things like that can really
break the concept of
alignment and visual balance
within your app.
So definitely focus
on these things.
And I think certainly, we've
covered most of these on
"Android Design in Action"
in episodes past.
But definitely, this is
one of the things you
should focus on.
Anything else before
I move on?
OK, let's do it.
NICK BUTCHER: So in at number
seven, we've got
living in the past.
Or as you said, if your app is
living in 2009, your users are
going to have a bad time.
ROMAN NURIK: It rhymes.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I'm
just visiting Reno.
I'm the South Park ski
instructor there.
Sorry, right.
So the first point I want to
make about this is the menu
button of shame, or the
legacy menu button.
It's kind of very
little excuse.
All of these [INAUDIBLE] we've
got on the slide here
generally point towards the fact
that you've not updating
your application to move
with the latest.
It's one thing to look at the
platform distribution stats
and say, hey, somebody uses
it on all their devices.
But that's not really being fair
to the users who are on
your devices, or have these
shiny, new devices.
Probably the people who are
downloading and installing
your application more often.
So we really think you need to
be looking at, maybe not the
blazing latest release.
But here we said you should be
targeting at least API 16,
which is the first Jellybean
release,
which came out at what?
Google I/O last year?
So over a year old.
If you're not targeting that
newer version, you're probably
missing out on some new
functionality, as well as
probably degrading some
of the functionality.
Because some of the shims
that their system
has to put in place.
Like the [INAUDIBLE] button.
So if you're below 14, I think
you've got a real big problem.
Because you're going to get
this legacy menu emulator
button, button of shame.
It could look terrible.
Especially on devices like the
HT1, where it puts up this big
bar across the bottom
of your application.
And really ruins all the time
and attention I hope you spent
on the rest of the design.
So really think about that.
And the other thing is
not picking up on the
modern look and feel.
So for example, if I'm using
an application, and it has
some kind of gingerbread
era and stying.
For example, it might
look kind of hollow.
But then you touch something,
and you
get that orange highlight.
Or you scroll and you get that
legacy, rounded scroll bar.
Maybe you're familiar
with that.
That really breaks the
experiences for me.
Suddenly it's just like, wow,
that was unexpected.
What's going on there?
So wherever possible, you want
to be using the latest and
greatest styles.
And building on top of them,
using them as your foundation.
I think when I often see this
is with spinners as well.
So you'll be using
an application.
And they set a style on the an
indeterminate progress spinner.
Often set the style
to indeterminate.
And they haven't used the
appropriate theme default
syntax for it.
So you get style spinner.
And it just looks completely
gross and out of place.
ROMAN NURIK: The other problem
with the loading spinner is
that the gingerbread era one
used frame animation.
So there are basically
8 frames, like
dik-dik-dik-dik-dik and so on.
And the hollow spinner
is actually
using a tween animation.
So it's a much smoother
rotation.
You actually see
each individual
frame as it gets rendered.
Well, not each individual frame,
but each point around
the circle.
So it's much, much better
to use the hollow style
interminable loading spinners.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, so I guess
the takeaway from this, what
we're trying to say here, is use
the latest and greatest.
And build on top of it.
ROMAN NURIK: Excellent.
Moving on?
OK.
Polluted Android.
Who is going to talk
about that?
NICK BUTCHER: I think
that's me again.
So there's a page on the design
guide called Pure Android.
And it is what it sounds like.
It's talking about don't borrow
metaphors from other platforms.
Don't use iconography or other
such from other platforms.
If you're building an Android
experience for your Android
users, then build an
Android experience.
I think we did a whole show
about branding inconsistency.
Whether you should be
consistent with--
and what that means.
What you should be consistent
with if you're on other
platforms, for example.
So I'll refer you back
to that for the deep
dive on this topic.
But essentially, if your app
doesn't conform to the Android
platform, you're the one who's
going to look out of place.
If I'm using 50, 60, 70 apps
on my Android phone, and I
switch to your app, and your app
doesn't look and feel how
an Android app should look and
feel, then you're the one
who's going to stand out.
So some very, very common things
we might see might be,
for example, using right
pointing carrots to indicate
that there's a level below
of information.
That just doesn't make
sense on Android.
I mean, we have a
very different
default transition animation.
So pointing right, and then
something expanding, and
fading just isn't line up
as well as going back.
It doesn't slide back
[INAUDIBLE].
So I guess there's just no
special metaphor there.
Especially with Android's use of
the horizontal metaphor for
moving between content.
So taps, for example.
You might page between
them like this.
But then if there's a right
arrow, does that mean I'm
going down?
Or I'm going sides?
And every time, it just
doesn't work.
So respect that.
Tabs.
On Android, tabs
go at the top.
So if you're doing tabs at the
bottom, basically you're going
to look out of place.
And it's going to be, why
is this app doing this
differently?
And the last one we call that
is just wholesale borrowing
from other platforms.
This is if you see, say,
iconography from another
platform, or a picker from
another platform, which just
looks completely out of place.
Just don't do it.
Just use the defaults, as what
you use is you expect.
And doing otherwise is being
quite arrogant and aggressive
toward them.
So stick with what the
platform [INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN NURIK: And that
covers it well.
Let's move on.
All right.
Was this me?
This may have been me.
I think this is me.
And actually, this plays
into what Nick was
mentioning about branding.
Which metaphors do you use?
Which UI patterns do you use?
This is the anti-pattern of the
navigation is my brand.
Or the entire app should
be mine, right?
I should control everything.
And generally, that's
the case.
You should control
visual styling.
You should control the
information architecture.
And we did a whole
segment on this.
But there are a few things that
you should really try to
use from the Android
design guidelines.
Obviously, Pure Android,
that's very important.
But also, anything related
to core app navigation.
So things like the action bar.
Things like tabs.
And also things like
the navigation jar.
So this anti-pattern is
basically apps that reinvent
the wheel, by creating
a custom top bar
with a centered title.
And then two actions, one on
the left, one on the right.
They're like a very
different looking
navigation jar indicator.
This basically isn't
Android, right?
I mean, Android users expect
an action bar the top.
The title should be
left aligned.
There are certain things
that should existent
in the action bar.
Navigation on the top left,
actions on the top right.
Or very poorly implemented
action bars.
And generally, this is because
of the lack of the tool kit
that allow you to bring the
action bar to earlier versions
of the platform.
But Action Bar Sherlock has
existed for quite a while.
And that's still
a great choice.
But also Action Bar Compat
was recently released.
So for designers and
developers--
well, for developers
especially--
if you're rolling your own
action bar, just stop.
Stop doing it.
And just use Action
Bar Compat.
But also, navigation drawers.
I'm not going to go through
all the details here.
But there are a lot of specifics
in what should and
what shouldn't go into
navigation drawer.
Generally, anything that's not
really core app navigation.
Something that the user's going
to be switching between
someone often.
That probably shouldn't go
to navigation drawer.
And we did another full episode
on this, so I won't go
into the details.
But if you're a developer, you
should definitely be using
Drawer Layout and Action
Bar Drawer toggle.
Try to avoid using any of the
other libraries out there that
don't implement this way.
Because you're not going to get
the same interaction that
the platform provides.
And in this vantage, I want to
quickly point out some things
that shouldn't go in the
navigation drawer.
So Home, Explore, Shop
Now, My Profile.
That's fine, and that's kind of
core top level navigation.
Things like search--
its navigational, but by
platform convention, it should
really go into the action bar.
So it does not belong here.
Settings, also in the
action overflow.
Help, About, Send Feedback, that
should all go into the
action overflow.
Anything linking to other apps
that your brand offers, that
should probably not go here.
Because chances are, folks don't
care about every app in
your portfolio.
So generally, you want to put
that-- if you do want to place
it in your app, put that
somewhere deeper in the app.
Maybe about your brand, and in
there, list the other things.
And then obviously,
random things that
people will never click.
Like my sister's friends'
website that I promise is
really awesome.
Please check it out.
That does not belong in
the navigation drawer.
So try to keep it simple.
Try to keep it to what's
in the guidelines.
Let's move on.
NICK BUTCHER: All right.
So number four is custom
non-Android sharing.
Now, I will note here that the
screen shots in this slide are
actually the positive, or the
good, sharing mechanisms.
Not the examples of bad,
or non-Android sharing.
I was looking for good
examples of that.
But there's a lot of them.
And we see it a lot.
But I didn't want to
sort of ding any
particular app out there.
So put in some positive
examples.
Positive reinforcement is the
name of the game here.
So Android has a great ability
to share or use this action
sending tent between
applications.
So you should always use it.
Always make it available
to your users.
Again, along the same
things that we were
talking about before.
It's just a frustrating
experience when the user goes
to try and share something, and
they're stuck with one or
two static options.
As you can see here, on my
phone, I have tons of
different apps installed.
I share to different
apps all the time.
And so not having the ability
to choose the one that you
want to share to is just a
really frustrating user
experience.
Just to quickly go over
the examples here.
On the left, you've got the
share action provider.
And so that's something that
goes directly in the action
bar, and actually has a pop up
menu that drops down there.
And you can choose from your
most recently, or most
frequently, shared
applications.
And then, the second one is
the standard system share
dialogue that you can
trigger using that
action sending tent.
And then on the right, this is
a custom example, actually,
from the Timely app, which
I really like.
So in this case, they actually
have listed just a few to
start with.
But you can see that they have
this little drop-down at the
bottom saying "more", which
actually goes and
pragmatically fetches
the rest of the
sharing options available.
So I guess the moral of the
story is try and always use
the system sharing tents.
If you really must for some
reason, have a list of
specific networks.
Maybe it's part of your
business goals
or something else.
You should still compliment it
with the standard action
[? send ?] based sharing
alongside.
ROMAN NURIK: OK.
Actually, one more thing.
This actually is in the Pure
Android guidelines, right?
So again, don't violate any of
the pure Android guidelines.
Try to adhere to those
as best as possible.
And this is--
I think it's called-- don't
hard code links to
apps in your app.
ADAM KOCH: And actually--
sorry, one last thing--
from a development standpoint,
it's actually much easier to
use the system sharing
tents than going off
and do it all yourself.
So I mean, from a development
standpoint, it's also a
positive thing.
ROMAN NURIK: Absolutely.
All right, moving on.
Mimicking Native with WebView.
ADAM KOCH: I think
this is me again.
So you can see here some quick
examples on the left.
We've got the ADIA YouTube
playlist loading in a WebView.
That's a great experience
there, to
browse the ADIA videos.
This is really just
a bit of fun.
Because actually, if you load
the YouTube website, it looks
fairly decent.
Because it switches to
the mobile version.
On the right there, you can see
the great example of the
ADIA, or the Android Design in
Action, or ADIA application
that's in the Google Play store,
which looks fantastic.
It's very responsive, works on
all different screen sizes,
really works great.
So let's move to some of
the talking points.
So the first point.
It's not genuine.
It's kind of like lying
to your users.
So it's not really the most
positive experience.
Especially if you're taking
up a lot of the core
UI with a web view.
And following from that, the
performance is generally going
to be degraded.
If you have a drawer that's
built using a web view, you're
going to notice that
it's not as smooth.
It's not as responsive.
It just doesn't behave like
the user would expect.
And then from the example on
the previous page, don't
package up a web app in an APK
just to be on Android.
Just for the sake of being
in Google Play
Store to be on Android.
We love web apps.
Web apps work great
on Android.
But when the user expects
them is in the browser.
In the Chrome browser the system
browser, where they
sort of understand that the
UI conventions and they're
viewing a web page.
NICK BUTCHER: And we're not
[INAUDIBLE] use WebViews at
all, right?
There's several components
where it makes sense.
Like Gmail, for example,
renders HTML and email.
And it makes perfect sense to
use, say, on a web view
control there.
Or if you're rendering some
news content, then perhaps
that makes sense.
I'm not saying don't
build your whole
application for this.
ADAM KOCH: Exactly, yeah.
So another good example is
Pocket, which uses a WebView
or HTML to render the
article views.
And it actually works
really well in
those particular cases.
We're really saying, don't just
throw a WebView into the
entire application, and make
it take over the sort of
standard core UI elements.
ROMAN NURIK: One last point I
wanted to make about web apps
versus native apps is.
There's a tendency for brands
to be like, oh we need to be
on Android, right?
And you mentioned this.
And we need to be on android,
so we need to
make a native app.
But a ton of Android usage,
that's regular users, most of
them use the browser
quite a bit.
So that you're not losing
those users.
They're going to access
your experience
through a different mechanism.
And if you think that a web
based solution is the best
option, then that's going to
work for a lot of users.
So don't immediately jump into,
oh, we need to just have
this hybrid thing, where we just
throw our entire web app
into a native APK So that
just doesn't work.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, and I think
you'll find, if you do go and
throw a web view in, make
it take over the entire
application, you're going to
violate a lot of these other
things that we've talked
about today.
Like the touch feedback, the
touch size, the UI elements,
the living in the past.
All these things are very hard
to do if you're going to use a
WebView to take over your
entire application.
Moving on?
ROMAN NURIK: Yep, moving on.
Nick, you want to talk
about onboarding?
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE] we
have poor onboarding UX.
So this is one of my
personal bugbears.
When you fire up an application
and 101 different
things are competing for your
attention at the same time.
And none of them are what I look
at your app for, which is
probably to see the content.
This is a personal frustration
of mine.
So there's many things that
people tend to throw in
at the first run.
So things like requiring
registration straight away, a
splash screen, popping up in
their own login provider, and
so on, and so forth.
And all of these things just
road bumps, or speed bumps,
stopping me from doing what
launched the app to do, which
is see some content.
So I would much rather see an
application that gets me to
content as quickly as it can,
and then delays any necessary
steps until they are
truly last minute.
So log on, for example.
Let me see some content, and
try and interact with it.
And if I try to do an
interaction which requires log
on, then prompt for it.
Because at that point, I can
understand exactly why you're
asking for this thing,
and so on.
Splash screens.
Another personal bugbear, it's
been in our design guidelines
forever, that you shouldn't
really use splash screens.
They don't really serve much
purpose, other than Delaying
you from getting to content
you want to see.
So if you think that it's the
only way to embed branding
into your application,
then I think
you have bigger problems.
There really are much better
ways to provide branding to
your application.
Like using the action bar, and
your palette, and so forth.
So I don't accept that
as an argument.
And then conversely, there's
lots of things you can use to
actually easy onboarding
process.
So for example, integrating with
popular log on providers.
So things like Facebook,
Twitter, Google+ have
excellent single click
sign on providers.
You can even do intelligent
things.
Like use the package manager.
Like a system component on
Android to detect of the user
has one of these native
applications installed, which
is a pretty strong indicator
that they-- a user of one of
these log on providing
services.
- And use that to
show or hide, or
reorder your log on options.
And they'll provide
a much slicker UX.
If you really, really must force
someone to log in, with
a username or password, for
example, then there's some
clever stuff you can do.
Like my phone already knows a
bunch of my email address or
usernames that were just
saved in the system.
You can query for these and use
them all to complete, or
pre-populate fields.
You can query the system
to the users.
Full name, and telephone
number, and
so on, and so forth.
So you can pre-fill a bunch
of different addresses.
I've even seen applications
going a step further.
If you really have to sign up
on the phone, do you really
want to have to sit there
and peck out a password?
Why not offer to auto-generate
some random string.
And let them hit Refresh
to rotate it
to something different.
Because the user can always just
recess it later, as long
as they have their
email address.
ROMAN NURIK: And they're
probably not going to remember
their password anyway.
It's like, I oh, I just want
to put in some password and
get past this screen.
NICK BUTCHER: Exactly.
So basically, do everything you
can to simplify the first
user experience, and get you to
content as soon as possible.
I think too often when we're
like designing and developing
apps, you've looked
at the application
so many times, right?
That you can see through
that process.
Or you logged in
the first time.
And after that, you then
continue to look at the
substance screens.
Don't you about the first
impression that you're making
on your users.
So super important.
I mean, this becomes even more
important if you're lucky
enough to become featured,
or picked by a blog, or
something like that.
You'd be surprised at how many
users will install your
application without fully
understanding the value
proposition exactly.
Understanding what it does,
just to try it out.
And it the first thing you see
is a bunch of overlays
explaining how to do stuff.
And logins and pop-ups.
They're forcing you to take more
steps before you get to
the actual content, to show
them the actual value.
Then, you'll have
a huge fall off.
ROMAN NURIK: On the converse,
completely on the opposite end
of spectrum, if I open up your
app and I see an immediate
empty list of you with
nothing there.
Just like a little plus button
on the top right, and really
just an empty screen.
That is also poor communication
of the value
proposition.
So empty states, which we'll
talk about very briefly.
Empty states for collections are
actually a really valuable
way of communicating that.
All right.
Moving on?
I think we're running
low on time.
The last one, number one.
We should have done a drum roll,
but I guess we didn't
have the time.
Android is not just phones
in portrait.
What this means is, if you're
developing an app and you have
a phone UI, don't lock
it into portrait.
Make sure that the user
can rotate into
landscape quite a few--
I think something that
chopped up here.
There's supposed to be a graphic
here, but whatever.
Quite a few users actually
use phones in portrait--
in landscape, rather.
Especially those with
maybe car docs, or
even desktop docs.
So for example, if you're a
sports app, there should be a
landscape dashboard view,
or something.
Especially if I'm in a car,
in some sort of doc.
If you're another type of app,
or you're a news app or
something, consider--
think about how you
can rearrange your
text so that it works.
And potentially even, switch
around your interactions.
Maybe horizontal goes to
vertical swipe, or
something like that.
I'm not really sure.
But the point here is, don't
force your users to hold their
device in a certain way.
And then another component of
this is that Android is not
only phones.
Android involves tablets
as well.
And the line between tabled and
phone is kind of blurry.
But really, Android
is really just--
well, I guess one of the ways
you can describe most Android
devices right now is touch
screens ranging from about
three inches to about
10 inches.
So responsive design is
really important here.
Make sure that your
app can respond to
the size of the screen.
And that it make best use of
white space, and best use of
content in all those different
configurations.
Not only that, Android
is also--
it's not only about touch.
There are some devices that are
D-pad focus at Google TV.
So definitely think about ways
in which you can response to
your device in both portrait,
landscape, tablet, phone, and
different input types.
NICK BUTCHER: I think it's
really important the point
you've thought about here
in this subtext.
That it sounds scary as well
saying being responsive to all
these different form factors,
and so forth.
But there really is so much you
can do very, very easily.
Things like upping the font
size when you have over a
certain amount of space.
Or changing the padding.
Or going to a centered margin.
Things like that can be
an hour of work, or
two hours of work.
And make your application
vastly
better on a larger device.
So it really is worth just
trying it out on a range of
devices or emulators and
seeing how it goes.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
With that, let's jump into some
quick honorable mentions
since we're running
super low on time.
First, per the guidelines for
launcher icons, your app icon
should really be a distinct
silhouette.
I know there are a couple of
Google apps that don't really
adhere to this guideline.
But that's definitely
something that
we're looking into.
Don't forget, like I mentioned,
don't forget the
empty states for your
collections.
So if you have nothing in a
list, if you have, let's say,
a to-do list.
And if you have nothing in
there, if you have no to-do
items, offer the user some ways
to add something to do,
maybe like a Plus button.
Or introduce what is going
to happen once you
press the Plus button.
NICK BUTCHER: Or you have some
sample content in there.
Like the to-do list might have
some sample to-do items.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, some sample
to-do items, like milk,
cheese, eggs, and so on.
Graphic assets should
be crisp.
I think most folks are starting
to his correctly.
But definitely make sure
to provide XHDPI.
And now with Samsung Galaxy
S4, HTC1, XXHTPIS.
Those are becoming the norm.
Take advantage of platform
features.
Make sure that especially if
you're in a category that is
heavy on widgets, like sports,
or news, make sure
to provide a widget.
And then make sure to provide
expendable notifications.
It's too easy, it's so, so.
NICK BUTCHER: I have to run.
ROMAN NURIK: Say what?
NICK BUTCHER: I have to go.
I'm getting kicked
out of my room.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh, OK.
All right, see you, Nick.
So make sure to provide
expandable notifications.
They're just so easy to add.
Lastly, notifications.
You should use them correctly.
Don't show too many
notifications.
Show them in appropriate
fashion.
Show them an appropriate time.
And then for the icons
themselves, the notification
icons in the status bar, make
sure to use white icons.
Don't add any color.
Because the status bar actually
automatically dims that.
So it's going to go from a blue
or red to some sort of
maroon, or some sort
of dark blue.
That's just weird.
So those are the honorable
mentions.
Very last, last but not least,
if you have any anti-patterns
that we missed out on today,
and you want to let us know
about them, and share or maybe
rant about them, just comment
about it in either the event
or the Google+ page.
And, yeah.
We'll see what you
come up with.
All right.
So I think that was
it for today.
Nick just dropped off, so I
guess we'll just end it here.
As always, I'm your
host, Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: See you
later, guys.
My name's Adam Koch.
And over in London, we
had Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: We had
Nick Butcher.
And this is, that's.
I'm not Nick Butcher.
That--
Nick Butcher.
All right.
See you guys next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]